[Music]
right we are expecting the release of
the DOJ inspector general's report on
deep state PI's abuse that's coming in
just a few weeks and from what we are
hearing from Senator Lindsey Graham it
is going to be quote ugly and damning
for the Obama era officials who abuse
their authority to spy on the Trump
campaign joining us now with further
insight Senator Lindsey Graham I watched
your interview and I know you pretty
well I want to take my time I want to do
it right and I want America to read all
of it let me interpret Lindsey Graham
for the American people they have a
lousy southern accent by the way yeah
well true it I have been told by people
it will with everything comes out it
will shock the conscience of a nation
you agree with that well here's what
you're done yeah yeah I think it's gonna
be really damning and ugly and people
did some really bad things that are
dangerous for the country but you'll
only find it on Fox you may find it a
little bit in the paper here's what I
predict it'll be 10% of the coverage
that the Muller report got and that's a
shame so just keep doing what you're
doing
here's the question it's not what did
Obama know and when he knew it
who told him and what did he do when he
was told I want to know who briefed the
president about their
counterintelligence investigation
against a Trump campaign
what about Carson you're gonna unravel
the riddle here what about Andy McCarthy
find the person who briefed the
president the counter in T Andy
McCarthy's contention there is no
counter intelligence right unless it
comes from the president it's the it's
the president's counterintelligence
investigation counterintelligence
investigation is designed to protect the
country from foreign intelligence
operation the FISA warrant is a Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Act it is not
a criminal investigation they found out
that Dianne Feinstein's driver may have
had connections to the Chinese
intelligence service they tell her and
she fires him right why did they not
tell Donald Trump
that we believe some people in your
organization may have contacts with the
Russians why did they tell Feinstein and
not Trump did they abuse the FISA
process
did they defraud the court did they open
up a counterintelligence investigation
not to protect the country but to get
Trump senators of the questions but it
will be soon answered senator I've read
it in the Nunez memo in the Grassley
grant memo that the bulk of information
for each FISA warrant was the Clinton
bought and paid for dossier okay now we
know that in fact the FBI DOJ everybody
was warned at least twice once by Bruce
or once by Kathleen kavlock you can't
trust it it's unverified Clinton paid
for it and Steele hates Trump but they
used it anyway then we find out as we
just discussed with John Solomon that
they never corroborated any of it and
when the FBI finally got around to it
around the time of the third renewal or
around the second or third renewal they
realized that this is basically all
totaled 90 plus percent BS why didn't
they know that when they signed the
first warrant or did they and does that
mean it's premeditated fraud on the FISA
Court what would be ugly and damning is
if you could prove that the document
they used to get the warrant without
which there would be no warrant was not
verified until later that they put no
effort into verifying the document
before they gave it to the court they
panicked
hey we got to figure out of this thing
actually is true I want the chart
disclosed to the public I want to tell
the truth nothing but the truth I want
to tell the story I want to declassify
everything that we can declassify so the
story tells itself here's what I think I
think they put no effort into verifying
the dossier until after they got the
warrant and when they tried to verify it
they came up with a with a dry hole
they're investigating two people here
Papadopoulos and Carter page I bet you
Donald Trump did not spend 10 minutes
with both of them I could guarantee it
did you see the gang of eight
materials where the FBI identified all
the shortcomings of this narrative in
2018 in the summer of 2018 did you see
that sir no I did not because I'm not in
the gang of eight but I want you to see
it this is not grand jury testimony that
will be compromised this is an
investigation into your government and
how it operated every American should
want to know as much as possible every
media outlet should be doing what these
other groups are doing suing to get the
information out I'm going to meet the
Attorney General this week to talk to
him about how to best tell the story I
don't want people to conjecture as to
what happened I want you to read it I
want you to see all the 302s that we
possibly can give to you I want you to
see the full FISA warrant application I
want to release the transcripts of the
confidential informants talking to
Papadopoulos I want you to hear in
real-time that the guy said I'm not
working sentence if I were it'd be a
crime and treason
senator the following I asked you do you
believe that is all likelihood Hillary
Clinton committed multiple felonies and
they rigged her investigation do you
believe that they used an unverified
Clinton bought and paid for Russian
dossier that later turns out to be all
lies to get a warrant to spy on a
president and then bludgeon a duly
elected president and try to remove him
from office and do you believe that high
Intel officials outsource intelligence
gathering to spy on the president
presidential campaign transition and
other Americans to circumvent American
log and spying against Americans do you
believe that's all true and I said
there's a good-faith reason to believe
that it's all true but I don't want to
need to tell you it's true I want you to
look at the pregnant what are the odds
that Sean Hannity's right okay just see
the harlots report what are the odds I'm
right I think Sean Hannity I think
you've been right about most of this
shine your investigative team is the
best in television just stay tuned weeks
from now you're going to see the harlots
report
I'll start calling these is a bad
accident in my life or visit them what
happened there's a bad accident my life
for some you know mid-morning raid at my
house that's not gonna be an accident
either I just asked you to bail me out
and send the cake with a file all right
senator thanks for your good work and
all seriousness this is not a joke this
is this is literally an attempt to rig
an election this is to favor one
candidate that should have been taped
that should have been charged with
felonies this is about that on doing an
election of soft cool against a duly
elected president bludgeoning him in so
many ways that it's unimaginable it
can't happen in this country